Dirty Jobs was a tribute to a guy named
Carl Noble Carl Noble was my neighbor
and my grandfather
um both of those things both of those
things and he was a magician
um a real magician no as good as they
can be no the kind of magician who you
know the guy woke up clean every day and
came home dirty every night and somehow
during the course of the day something
magical happened something was fixed
something was repaired something was
built the guy could build a house
without a blueprint take your watch
apart put it back together blindfolded a
combustion engine uh a plumbing line
whatever it is right he was drug-free
he was drug free oh yeah I mean as far
as I know I I never saw him drink to
tell you wow but he um he only went to
the seventh grade but by the time he was
30 he was the chief electrical inspector
for the state of Maryland licensed
electrician plumber steam fitter
pipefitter welder architect he he could
do all that stuff right so I thought I'd
follow in his footsteps I worked as his
Apprentice for a couple Summers the
handy Gene is uh recessive right so all
the stuff he could do all the stuff he
could do naturally well it it didn't
come easily to me right I I one day I
was working with him on a on a concrete
pour on some construction site and I um
I just bitched up the mix completely
ruined it you know and uh I was probably
16 at the time and he said Mike you know
just because you uh
you can be a Tradesman right just got a
different toolbox yeah and I mean that
that advice changed my life and anyhow
long story short I got in the
entertainment business I I started
pursuing things that I I didn't I I
didn't know I would like and I didn't
know I cared about like singing and
acting and writing and hosting and and
narrating you know I I got into all of
this at a community college as I tried
to put a different toolbox together
and um you know Whaley's on the way and
I I freelanced for for 20 some years in
in the TV business had a lot of jobs
and then uh my mother called I was
working for CBS in San Francisco on a
show called evening magazine terrible
little show one of those half hour
things that comes on after the news
right yeah sounds bad it's awful
um but I was good at it you know I was I
was good at creating the illusion of um
of competence in in shortcuts yeah like
Russell Wilson
sure yeah
sure you said it not me
um and so I'm sitting in my cubicle one
day uh preparing for the show that night
and my mom calls me and she says Michael
you know your um your grandfather turned
90 today and he's not gonna be around
forever and I was thinking would it be
great if uh before he died he could turn
on the TV and see you doing something
that looked like work
oh
my mother no no my my mother hits me
with this right so I take a uh I take
one of my cameramen
uh actually I go to the boss and I say
hey why does evening magazine always
have to be hosted from like a winery or
a or an art museum you know why can't it
be hosted from a a factory floor or a
construction site or a sewer yeah he's
like you want to host evening from a
sewer and I said why not he goes Mike I
don't give a [__] no one's watching the
show do whatever you want so I
I took my cameraman into the sewers of
San Francisco
and what happened down there
um is actually a a book I wrote a couple
years ago it was it changed my life the
um the whole experience in the sewer the
rats the roaches the the just the
endless
chocolate tide that washed over us and
and kept me from doing the job I was
trying to do all of that forced me to do
the only thing I could do which was work
with the sewer inspector who was down
there replacing these rotten bricks you
know that was his job I was just there
to to shoot raps to host the thing
anyhow that footage uh wound up on the
air and it turned into Dirty Jobs it
crushed and so my granddad saw the first
episode died oh killed him huh killed
him killed my own pop
no yeah he had an amazing life and he he
he lived long enough to see me doing
something that as my mother said looked
like work right and so uh and then Dirty
Jobs blew up yeah yeah and so this this
is you know I'm I'm I know you've seen
this kind of thing in Show Business I
hadn't at that point I'd had a lot of
jobs but I'd I had never gotten mail
from people saying you think that's
dirty you should see what my father does
my brother my cousin my uncle my sister
where do you see this
and that's when I was like oh
oh
this is not a show this is something
else this is um I a love letter to work
it's a romp it's I mean a truly
unscripted you're back before reality
was reality it was like it was a very
unusual thing for Discovery to put on
the air
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one